well I've worked for a couple of crazy
people and that's never very pleasant
having an editor who changes their mind
all the time is very trying
disconcerting point of the thing to live
with because you just you know you go
left and suddenly they say no go right
and you say red and they said but we
said blue so having a difficult having
an indecisive editor is a very painful
thing in journalism in my experience the
most difficult job kind of have pretty
great jobs I didn't love being an
assistant I just didn't love the
schlepping of the suitcases in the
trunks and you know coming four hours
later and having to get up there for
hours earlier than everybody else and
having to you know try and iron scary
dresses and not do a good job so I don't
I knew I didn't love being an assistant
I want to move out of that schlep role
schlep the schleppy role sooner rather
than later
God you know what I look at the weather
and I look feel my mood and go into the
closet and just make a pick you know I'm
going off to the collection so that's a
real considered thing as it's a suitcase
it's a finite amount of clothing I have
to pack first season on packing for you
know the great cocktail party called the
you know the fashion weeks in Milan and
Paris I just look at the weather and and
feel my mood and go and kind of go for
it and hope that I've made the right
decision I'd have to say probably one of
the biggest choices is you know how
higher the heels going to be that day am
I going for flats so and that that will
determine whether it's a slightly more
dressed up or slightly more casual point
of view for the day
yeah yeah you know this that moment
where you've got to say in the morning
before you leave okay we're good to go
I'm liking the outfit I'm good and then
son you think oh god no I'm so not right
this is so not what I should have been
wearing I'm do dressed up you know I'm
wearing feathers everyone else is going
to be in t-shirts I'm going to feel
overly dressed but I think one of the
prerogatives of getting a little bit
older is I don't care anymore I've made
my decision and this is what I'm going
to wear if I'm too dressed I'm too
dressy oops that's okay I'm a fashion
editor if I'm not dressed appropriately
enough well that's just my personal
style and choice that day so I think
with with experience comes a certain
sang flaw about making decisions and
sticking with them and not carrying as
much